Arghhhhhh... arghhhh
Hey, how is it going bros?
My name is Pewwwdiepie
Welcome back
to Walking Dead episode 3
Fuck!
*Laugh*
I forgot to play it..
It's been out for 2 days
I'm so sorry.. (you better be poods)
I don't know how this flew by me
It's out
It's fucking out
Of course I'm gonna play it.
Of course!
I've seen all the comments now.
That lip sync though
As always, a little recap
Aw shit!
her... she's dropped it off.
Oh yea we shot that fuckin guy
And then Clementine was like 'woah'.
*Apple*
If you hear snoring during this, Edgar is on my lap and- he's asleep
He's making alot of snoring noises, ok..
Jesus
Oh yea now I remember it had such a good ending!
Where... that guy is
...his brother
Yeah he's reunited with his brother
Cool! Well here we go,
Let's play another episode of the Walking Dead Season THRAY!
BOII
I'm excited... I'm happy
I got Edgar here..
I can't make decisions from this!
Uhhh...
Ok, you can go back if you're so scared
That's rite
Okay so this is way back.
Why are we playing this part?
..like she's already dead, it doesn't matter
Whats the point of this?
So we're reminded of the brother or some shit?
Like, why, why are we playing this?
I don't want to play this part
Come on
Let's take it and go
Heyy look we got the propane tank
Now we can make food.
How do you-
How can you tell... there's no way you can tell!
Right?? It's hard to tell
They're still heavy
YES!!!
KILL HIM!!
KILL HIM!!!!
We know he's not gonna die
like what's the point?
Its hammer time
It's someone she knows?
Oh shit
It's a little boy
SNAP HIS NECK
SNAP HIS NECK CMON
LIKE A FISH
C'mon boy
There you go, you're welcome
Thanks for the hammer...
BITCH!
Jesus Christ
Now I'm not even sad that you died
So what he's dead
Yeah
That's right
He's.. dead
ZOMBIES!
Just call them ZOMBIES!
Zombies.
No- ZOMBIES DAMMIT!
I'm here for you
Get dat.. pussay
Sorry I uh...I have... dyslexia
Okay? I'm sorry
Can't help it
Was that-
Did you guys hear my... notification sound?
I'm sorry if that- you heard that
I don't know new computer aight
It's different settings
Sorry. I just realized you might've heard like... like whatsapp or some shit
Fuck
Oops
Better turn that off
Okay
Oopsy
I always hate watching youtube videos and then-
We already know that they go, so why not just- TIME TO GO
Trump. Let's go to Trump
He was right all along
That's why they're mexican in this game
Sorry, Hispanic
That was a joke, by the way
That was a joke, I'm sorry
Listen, you're a little shit it's not your call
Fuck off, Jerry
Gabe, whatever
Talk to me when your balls have dropped, GABE
He's dead, okay? And you'll be next.
Okay, alright fine
Your friends are- you have no friends
Let's get real here Gabe, no one likes you..
That counts me, as well..
Oh, uhhh..
We saw your friend, he's pretty dead
He was a, zombie...
A zombie...
just say it..
Yeah you plan-
I could bear it
I could definitely bear it
Now..
when you shut the fuck-, sorry.. *chuckles*
Sorry
Awww, cute
Uhh, that we love him, how about that?
It's called love man
Well, if he becomes a zombie, I wouldn't love him..
So we don't forget..
Eh, he's so annoying
I'm trying to sympathize with him,
but like he's too annoying..
What's that look?
Ooohh..
Ooh..
What's happening?
Oh...
Telltale presents. HELLO!
Ahh
The drama
So they yeah- th- that used to be...
...her husband
The guy that we saw in the trailer, if you rememb-
Sorry in the recap
If you remember
They wrote the note
"Dad,we had to move somewhere else"
Okay so he's the dad
Of course! Of course!
Don't know where, but Kate says we are not safe here
Okay
That- i- That is actually interesting
Now i understand.. why they showed this part
I just thought it seemed kinda random
Obviously-
There's a reason for everything
I wanna know more about his Baseball backstory
We've only really seen him
Wear the clothes, I guess?
I'd take the bat-
I'd bring the bat
C'mon. Its a zombie apocalypse
Yeah bring the mayo and not the knife you fucking moron
I guess that was pudding wasn't it...
She brings the.. kush
Think that's the van in- from Breaking Bad huh?
Cute
I'm starting to-
Episode 3: Above the Law
I don't know I- I- think I would enjoy THIS stage of the outbreak more than the beginning
You know the whole- the shock and all that
It'd be annoying, but I think once you get over it
Might be pretty cool to, you know kill some people
Jokin- *coughs*
His joke is-
Ahh...
Awkward.
This is awkward, they need to-
Thank God...
Are they happy or-
Oh, she's NOT dead
I thought-
*nervous chuckle*
Oh my God...
This is complicated
Uhh...
What's happening?
It froze.
The game froze.
Hello?
It- It crashed
Excellent.
Good game.
Man, Edgar is snoring so loudly.
You hear that?
*chuckles*
*Edgar snores*
Shut the fuck up-
But she has to be checked bro
*laughs*
To check. That's pretty-
oooooooh
REJECTED!!!
MOTHAFUCKA!
*laughs*
Clem is gonna get in trouble
Clem you're fucked. If... I- I don't kn-
God damn Clem. C'mon
C'mon girl
You're smarter than that
You better than that
This is got- y- you know trouble is coming
You just know it's waiting for ya.
Uhh- it's not gonna be good. It's probably not gonna be good.
I.. It's never good in this game so I don't know wh-
Ah!
That's nice.
She-
She has one now?
What're they-
What're they talking about?
Oh yeah
Wait- she didn't know that?
Uhmm...
I'm shocked too
It- h-
It's his brother too
*chuckle*
Yeah...
That's true
Yup!
*chuckles*
ooooooooh!
WOOH! BOI!
OHH!
*painful hiss*
*awkward overload*
It's definitely possible
Yeah
W- he couldn't have known obviously
Yeah I mean, this could fix it
Don't look at me like that
Yeah
*shocked inhale*
Clevy...
Yes.
*truth hurts*
We already know he's a bad guy from previous...
Yeah. Previous episodes
Yeah
Clemy could get him in a fist fight though
Ahhh...
Yeah- we should just play along-
Just for now...
Yeah
That's when we take... off our pants
...and show our nipples
...his nipples
OHH!
He-
Not Jes- you're not gonna-
Uhm... I'll get you out
He's right there
He's right there, the guy you need to put in a good word for
What are you talking abou- you can't say that in front of him
*chuckle* What the hell?
Oh, they don't like each other
Clem- If Clemy- you know, if that's Clemy's enemy, it's my enemy too
Alright? *chuckles*
Clemy gave her- h- him the old uh, "I need to shit my pants and I don't like you" look
That's a deadly look
Lot of people can't master it like Clemy can
Does that poster say "Sexy"?
Am I the only one who read that?
Yeah?
Kh-
Yeah, that's a good answer
Yeah don't fight- I wouldn't fight with this guy right away
You know?
I didn't mean... for that-. That seems pretty cool
It's got a garden and shit
Okay, what- what is he saying?
Yeah, because of your guys
So he doesn't know about the relationship yet
Yeah that was fuck- yeah yo-
Your person shot her
She was pretty annoying honestly
Yeah I'm gonna tell him. I'ma tell him.
Sh- they shot her in the head
That someone was you motherfucka
Well they did
Hey, it's maxmoefoe here
I didn't shot the little girl I'm sorry
We were ambushed
Oh shit
Okay, alright
That makes sense
-It doesn't seem that bad
I think we should play along
Exactly. We'll follow you-
Wdyu- What does that mean? Fuck you
So is Badger one of the other leaders perhaps...
THAT could be one of the leaders
If I was in a zombie apocalypse I'd be the-
Five *chuckles*
She looks trustworthy
I w- I would go full mo- mohawk you know?
Chop up
I- I- I'd be like M- M- Mad Max just all crazy like-
EAAAAAGHH!!!!!
S- freak people out
I realized no one asked but-
...this is my little plan
This is my little... idea what I wanna do
Uh... we waited
I guess?
*whispers* Three mon-
Ye-
Yeah why
No... Not me mama
Mama!
Coulda texted
Yeah I stuck with them. I- It's my wife now
Don't touch me motha fucka
I don't like you
Alright? I want your wife...
...and I'ma steal it
Per-
*smile*
So th- is this-
We're outside of DC is that what they said?
Looks pretty Central to me...
A'ight, I'm sure she's gonna be fine
We need to get you some real food. Stat
Turn you into one of these...
Uhmmm....
"Much better now"
Oh she smiled!
Oh-
WOAH!
She probably just had to fart
That happens to girls. They don't fart in public
Se- I told you!
It's just a f-
Really?
She's talking about her fart
*painful hiss*
Mmm that's not gonna work...
Okay- fine, fine...
Just for the- sake of the story
I-
I feel like I- I would've- I would've stayed
I would've st-
Just a fart
I think Edgar farted
Yeah- wh- why is he questioning them?
"Lingard"?
Real- who did it again?
Oh right the girl
*chuckle*
*kiss*
*chuckles*
Awh it's so awkward...
That guy is screaming "Crazy Scientist"
Isn't he?-
Edgar, you keep burping. It smells bad like stop-
Stop
S- can you stop burping now?
Here's my little Jesus baby
*chuckles* Look at him *chuckles*
*kisses Edgar*
What 'guys'?
A- In a zombie apocalypse? I would definitely take the vegetables
...honestly
Why are we talking to this?
Oh I see. So they are- okay
I feel like that was the only good answer
Oh yeah
Oh shit
Oh shit they know...
We're not friends
*chuckle* So childish!
Yeah- but we didn't know they had it
Yeah and we s-
Oh shit
"YOUR PEOPLE KILLED MY NIECE"
Oh shit well I-. Okay well- you know what, maybe that could have gone...
...a little better
I don't trust you
This was meant to happen no matter what happens
I thought we messed up but I- I realized this was meant to happen
I really don't think there is any other way
You always think that "Oh no I did something wrong"
And then it's like "Nope"
It's the only way
Ah thanks
Woah. Damn. Taking that guy down she's-
Dude she's so tiny. How- how can she put him down?
*chuckles* He's just laying there
Uh oh...
Heyy
*chuckle*
Duffle bag. Let's see what's inside
Hey we got a shotty and a map
It's a baseball bat
How the fuck did he put that there?
Alright. Uhhh.... So we are here I guess?
No? We're.... here?
M'kay
Oh really?
Which leads-
I don't fucking know the constellations.
That one?
Great. Okay... how about this one?
YES!
"DEAL WITH IT"!
DEAL WITH IT BOY!
Well I guess I'll get their flashlight
And I can stick it
Is the trigger broken on that one?
Why don't they keep the duffel bag that might be useful
Okay. Alright.
Maybe I'm the only one expetiesed in zombie apocalypse with my mohawk and my glasses and-
AGHHHH!!
It'd be so fucking cool, get a dirt bike
Eat someone's pet
You know?
Okay alright. Just me apparently?
Am I the only one here?
Yeah yeah. I wanted to tap that ass but you know it's complicated alright?
There's other women out there as well. You don't have to run-
Mac- douche- douchebag
Well you know I always had the hots for my brother's... wife
Great
You got that right- you got them right
Neither does-
Awwwww!
I like him. He's a good character
Jesus...
He's gonna walk on water. I know it
Y'know at least we have Jesus on our side
We better scoot
*chuckles*
C'mon Jesus lead the way
Clementine has a surprisingly small part in this one
She's just like a side character- she's just there
She's like a... accessory or som-
"Look alive" that's rich
DAMN JESUS. DAMN.
WOAH! JESUS!
JESUS! JESUS!
Damn. I bet he knows Kung S- Fu as well
AND it's baseball time
No. Nevermind.
*laughs* That's cool
That's kinda cool
I didn't press it in time I guess-
IT'S BASEBALL time
Home Run mothafucka
Or that, that- that was cool
Dude, did you not hear my cool one liner?
Oh my god
No just run
AHHH! Shit boy...
Just run dude
Dude you're terrible at this
C'mon! C'mon!!!
Someone's gonna save me in three... two...... one...
There you go. Heyy it's Clementine
Hey Clemy! Damn Clemy calm down
Eesh...
*laughs*
She's so cool!
Oh we're- great, you wasted it
You wasted it dude...
How does that stay on his back?
Is that glue? or magnetism? or-
Also an asshole. He's an asshole
You can't trust assholes as well...
Aww Clement-
Them...
Tr- *shocked inhale*
What?
Okay then
Are we talking about Kenny?
I hope we're talking about Kenny 'cause I miss Kenny
I like Kenny... a lot
Oh my God IT'S ME!
Oh my Gawd
Look at that face. That looks like...
PewDiePie's face
Yes I rhymed, face with face
Face the fact that I'm- I have a face
Ok I'll- I'm sorry
Don't cough on me you disgusting-
Just punch him
Awww Clem is so cute
Is the baby fat? Or is he just a baby? I can never tell...
You know what I mean?
LOOK IT'S ME!... BOI!
"Vancomycin"
Uhmm...
Kay?
Ah! Got it
So take the needle as well
Take all of it for I care
And she's going to get discovered, in three... two... one...
I mean- how does she know the dosage? and-
What?
Ah Jeesh...
How can you not?
C'mon it's a little baby...
It's gon- hasn't got a shot yet... literally
Oh fuc- fucking hell!
Okay well I guess no difference... really
There you go
Jee-
That's right Clementine
Hey it's me in the back!
Look at me
WHAT?
Awww...
BOI!
I mean- at least he's not her responsibility anymore
You know?
Arghhhhhh... arghhhh
*painful hiss*
Oooh that was cruel...
That was cruel dog...
Awww...
If Clem is sad, I am sad...
Awhhhwhhhh... *painful hiss*
I mean you did- you did steal th- okay...
Oh was- it's THAT close?
Was that a hipster zombie?
Damn... HO!
YES!!
Smackaroo! Clemy sets them up
Arm knuckle. Bam!
and Jesus...
...leads the way
and Viking Jesus? I don't know what he does actually
Heyy did it
That's not gonna hold
"It MIGHT give"?
What're you talking about- lift it
Guys? A little help?
A little help maybe?
Uhmm... Alright. Well... it's up to me now
The door we tried- Uhh... The car maybe there's something in the car
So if someone stole the wheels there might be hydraulic press!
YES!
Ah!... Fuck!
It's inside!
Okay well I'm just gonna open here
Three two one and slam. Done
Bitch!
DAMN that sound is good
A'ight let's get it
...and let's put it there
Jesus! Just use your strength!
YES!
*laugh*
*aggressive whisper* I'm trying I'm trying
Here we go. Here we go-
One tw-
OH!
HURRY JESUS!
C'mon Viking Jesus!
BOI! Killed it. Killed it.
That was awesome
Double high- Okay maybe not-
Aa... Ah I don't really care about Conrad
Ah that's bad- Ah
Eh Conrad
Wha- What're you gonna do about Conrad?
Eh... It's Con- It's Conrad
It's Conrad, okay? Alright
I don't really care
Oh what the fuck?
Jesus Christ...
Clemy... put the gun down
Yeah...
I don't like- I don't like going against Clementine
But I-
I don't- May- We should definitely open right?
Eh.... It'll j-
Fuck this game for making me go against Clementine
Not likin' it.
Okay...
Ah fuck you alright?
"You're a heartless bas-"
Mhmm!
Yeah?
I would lie, no matter what the truth is
About stuff like that-
What?
WHAT?
AJ's ALIVE?!
Bitch what?
What?
THE MEDICINE DID IT RIGHT-
He wouldn't lie I don't buy it I don't know-
Ah shit...
Ah it's my fucking Whatsapp again I'm sorry I forgot
Ah I'm a- piece of shit YouTuber
It's a new computer okay? I forgot
OHH!! *laughs* TOP OF THE MORNIN' TO YA!
How did they get that door open?
Am I gonna have to... press- Ughh...
"W-A-S-D"
Ughh.. ughh...
Sss- did it
What is that?
What is it? What is it?! WHAT IS IT?!
WHAT IS IT?
What is it?
Awhh.. Awhh.. Eugh...
"Property... Air"?
What? What? What?! What?! WHAT? WHAT? WHAT? WHAT?!
*shocked inhale*
They're u-
So they take over cities...
I would kill those guys
I know I sound crazy but no I'd f-
I'll get my mohawk out and-
SURPRAA!
Kill 'em... *clap* Kill 'em!
KILL THOSE FUCKERS
Kill 'em. YEAH!
BOI!
Shoot him in the dick
Shoot 'em
Fuckin' idiot...
This is why... you need a mohawk alright?
This would never happen on my command
Never let 'em talk. You shoot 'em mid-sentence. They never expect mid-sentence...
...killings... you know?
NOPE!
The classic Walking Dead dramatic sequence music
*annoying music imitation* So annoying...
OH! That looked like it hurt
Then you press 'E'
Then you press 'Q'
And then you press a 'Q' again
*laughs*
And then you press 'T' like a Cutee
Sorry
Then- have a- mug
Was that a double replay of me hitting him with a mug?
No no no no no you don't want that
That's a Swedish invention fuck off!
AAAGHHHHHH...
Damn dog...
Hey it's- Viking Jesus help me please
What are they doing squatting?
What the fuck does that mean?
"Fly"- Oh shit dog
I would've-
Nice!
SHOTTY!
Ah shit I missed his penis
*laughs*
"Th"- Yes...
"This"-
Oooh I'd kill him so hard
YESS!!!
Hey thanks for showing up
I'm gonna enjoy this
"What are you waiting for DO IT"
SMACK!!!
Oh he's not dead
He's not fucking dead
Yes...!
How you feelin'? How does that feel?
*whispers* Ahh! Fuck!!
SHMACK!
Shmack
EUGHHHHHHH!!! WHAT THE HELL!??
*laughs*
Oh my God...
It was mash potatoes man
Heyy
I need to start learning those moves you know for the apocalypse
How do you like- you know... dig that
Shoot him in the... dick
C'mon shoot him in the-
"YOU BETRAYED THE LAW!!!"
He doesn't know...
Mid-sentence- *gunshot mouth sound*
Easy choice...
*clap* We should've done it mid-sentence, but that pretty fucking good
Alright? "I'm beggin-" *gunshot mouth sound* that would've been better
But you know I'll take it. I'll take it
That was good. Good- good execution
Ah it's fun
Jesus...?
Jesus y- you don't need to judge me
Thanks
That's right Clem. You're-
I want Jes-
God damnit
Ah...
That's- well at least we have Viking Jesus
I'll do it for Kate and not for you
YES!
It's weird I'm starting to like him a little bit
"Noo don't go I love you guys" *laughs*
What the fuck was that...
Ohhhh boy...
This is a mess...
I wanna- I- It's gonna end pretty soon I imagine and-
Uhhh................
It always end on a cliffer you know?
"Red" barrel
See that reference there?
A'ight
Aw...
Thank Clem. I really appreciate your support on that one
How about a brother fist?
Okay then. Alright then
That's cool...
Alright "WASD" here
Uh.. Top of the mornin to ya
I am pressing 'W', I really feel like I'm playing the game right now wow
Look at this, I'm looking- looking everywhere
It's almost like it's a game
Hello how're you doing? That was fun
That was really fun
Oh so they know who I am
*chuckles*
YES!
Perfectly shaped ball stone
Let's hit the... we can hit that I guess?
Or we can hit... that?
Or... uh... I would probably hit that
Clearly a distraction. Like clearly
"Still got it boy... still got the throw yeahhh boy...
Sorry
Let's get her, and get the hell out of here
How'd we get in so easily?
This is not gonna end well...
It's the little shit head
She doesn't like that
Yeah?
Pretty much yeah
Now is not the time guys just get out
Well he's still your dad
We can find your dad later
How are they moving in this town without anyone noticing them?
Am I the only one-
I mean everyone is looking for them
Well this went easier than I thought
Yeah c'mon Gabe
Arghhh... Gabe!
Uhhhh you're so lame
Fine
Fine...
Ohhhh *painful hiss*
Damn you a cold ass bitch Gabe
I respect that
I respect that...
Who's- Who's Stuart?
Maybe that was a reference...
Alright well we didn't 'suade Gabe we didn't- we didn't 'suade him over
At least we got the wife
And Clementine's respect
*whispers* That's all that matters to me baby
Ah dude, you gotta fart again?
Don't- Tell me what you want, what you really, really want
Yeah what an asshole...
Ah...
Well- Uh-
She's in no fit to fight
That's stupid I wouldn't do this
Yeah look, see what happened
Really? That was it? C'mon...
Ughh...
Well you deserted us!
What's happening? What's happening?
It crashed again! Dude like- what the fu-
Oh here we go
Yes
Explain. Come on!
Lonnie, don't betray me Lonnie
Lon-
LONNIE
Lonnie no-
At least Lonnie is honest
Oh shit...
Oh shit
Maybe it IS the brother
Oh shit maybe it was the brother
We'll support out brother for now
Honestly not a bad idea
Okay then maybe not
Uhhhh... you can tell he was lying
No. You're gonna end it like that? You fuckers...
God damn it...
You kidding me? Yeah, that is the endin-
FUCK!
Okay...
"Did you honor your brother's request?"
"DId you s- try and save"- yeah-
Who would let a kid die?
"You and 66%- destroyed Badger's skull"
Nice...
"You and 40% killed Max"
Okay so not everyone kil- killed Max then...
Uhhh...
"Leave with Kate"? Okay that was pretty close
Alright
And... uhh...
No I'm good
*stretches*
You still here? Are you still here?
Uhmm... that was fun! That was really fun to play
I- I still like The Walking Dead
It's not as good as it used to be, no- no doubt about that
like- it's very little focus on Clementine
and th- all these other characters keep introduced like-
Name one character name that was still in this one that was in the other two seasons
Clementine- it's just Clementine
like wh- why are they so set on replacing all these characters?
like is there... problem with voice actors they didn't want to stay?
like- I don't understand why-
The point of these is that you build a relationship with characters you really care about and-
and you- that transitions, you know, throughout the seasons and-
We're in Season 3 mid- mid now and-
Ehh... it's too much new I don't really care
You learn the concept of how the game works like-
No matter what you do your consequences doesn't REALLY matter
It doesn't- doesn't feel like that at least and-
In the beginning, you were kinda under the spell that, "Awh maybe-...
...Oh shit he's gonna remember that" and you're like-
"OH MY GAAD"
You know, has that ever really felt like a consequence? I don't really think so
I'm really just playing these for the sakes of the story
and I think it's- it's fun to catch up and see what's gonna happen
But I'm not like...
As invested as I used to be
I will 100% play episode 4
Sorry this WAS episode 4- Episode 5
Or was it? No this is episode 3
Now I'm a little confused
Anyway, I hope you enjoyed regardless uhhh...
and maybe- maybe you enjoyed it, or not
Let me know in the comments I'm curious
Uhh. but other than that, thank you so much for watching
And I hope you had fun anyway, and uh-
*brofist kiss*
Stay awesome bros...